hey fellow artists check out my
beautiful art this may surprise you but
I made this with the small assistance of
AI yeah I could tell what no you can't
the perspective is wrong I mean the
Shadows are off where's the light source
also what's going on with her giant arm
and that weirdly positioned neck it's
visual diarrhea that's uncalled for okay
this is a beautiful lady you wouldn't be
this critical if I hadn't used AI yes I
would that's kind of what I do this took
serious effort okay says a lot about you
more than anything doesn't it you
artists are bullies girl all snobs I
can't wait for AI to destroy your career
it AI will democratize art for people
like me like
who lazy people